bonsoir nouvelle édition du journal de
la rédaction le point sur l'actualité
locale et aujourd'hui nous parlerons
notamment de thibaut mathieu n'a pas
encore 30 ans il est déjà présent à
l'onu à new york
versailles et et délégué du rotary club
international et nous parlera de son
rôle sur ce plateau dans quelques
instants la croix rouge accueille depuis
quelques jours une soixantaine de
migrants dont son centre des matelots à
versailles en septembre et 81 réfugiés
arrivés à beaune elle nous faisons le
point sur la situation dans les yvelines
ils étaient près de 3 millions de
téléspectateurs devant m6 hier soir pour
assister à la qualification finale de
top chef 2 xavier pincemin second du
trianon palace à versailles nous sommes
allés le rencontrer dans ses cuisines
portrait à la fin de cette édition et
pour débuter ce journal nous allons
faire un point sur la situation des
migrants des réfugiés dans le
département avec vos williams
bonsoir il y a deux semaines environ 60
migrants se sont installés du côté de
versailles
bonsoir fried alors oui tout d'abord
faisons un petit point sur la situation
dans les yvelines alors souvenez-vous en
septembre soixante dix huit réfugiés
était arrivé à bonne aide dans le centre
d orantes dirigé par l'association
habitat et humanisme
c'est il était arrivé d'allemagne et à
l'époque c'était les premiers réfugiés
syriens accueilli officiellement par la
france à ce moment là françois hollande
avait l'assaut annoncé l'accueil sur
deux ans de 24 mille réfugiés en
provenance de syrie
dans ces réfugiés ont décompté trois
nationalités différentes
47 syrie 1,30 irakien et un palestinien
et donc aujourd'hui qu'elles sont
devenues ces réfugiés eh bien ils ont
quitté les lieux en réalité ne sont
restés là-bas seulement que quelques
semaines d'état les avait placé le temps
de s'occuper de toutes les démarches
administratives
il y avait seulement deux familles des
autres étaient des hommes qu'on dit
isolé ils ont donc été placés dans des
familles d'accueil ou bien dans des
logements collectifs
pour autant aujourd'hui le monastère
accueille toujours des réfugiés et des
migrants en fait le centre n'est pas
restée vide très longtemps en octobre ce
sont des afghans qui sont arrivés là bas
et puis des teams et des tibétains
quelques mois plus tard je suis revenu
il y à un peu plus d'un mois pour les
rencontrer à ce moment là il y avait
deux afghans un pakistanais et 59
tibétains et pour autant une fois qu'ils
sont arrivés il faut leur trouver un
statut définir un statut est ce
qu'aujourd'hui les choses sont plus
claires c'est une question un petit peu
compliqué en réalité il y a deux sortes
de réfugiés c'est un petit peu comme si
on faisait la différence entre le mot
migrants et le mot réfugiés d'un côté on
a les demandeurs d'asile de l'autre ce
sont les réfugiés statutaires c'est
l'état qui décide d'accorder ou non le
statut de réfugiés statutaires et en
général ça se fait en fonction du pays
d'origine de la personne par exemple les
syriens qui était arrivé en septembre et
qui fuyaient la guerre étaient des
réfugiés statutaires
mais écoutez plutôt isabelle mort est la
directrice du monastère des eaux rente
qui nous explique à quoi correspondent
ces deux statues de niveau de ce qu'il y
a les demandeurs d'asile et les réfugiés
statutaires la majorité
nous avons donc les réfugiés statutaires
donc ça signifie qu'ils ont obtenu le
droit d'obtenir un titre de séjour de
dix ans en france est de travailler en
france les demandeurs d'asile restent
ici en attendant donc que lors que leur
dossier soit étudié par le froid qui est
l'organisme qui en france stature sur le
fait de vous donner votre votre statut
pardonnez-moi de réfugiés ou pas donc là
ça peut être plus long ça peut être ça
peut prendre un peu de temps
alors en ce qui concerne l'avenir des
personnes qui se trouvent au monastère
c'est comme pour les précédents
l'objectif c'est pas qu'il reste advitam
eternam dans ce centre qui reste un lieu
de transit
c'est soi qu'on leur trouve un logement
ou bien qu'on leur confie l'attendent
leur régularisation pardon en ce qui
concerne leur journée isabelle nous a
fait faire un petit tour des dieux et
nous expliquer tu avais donc les cours
de français qui vont avoir lieu pendant
deux heures et qui seront suivis cet
après midi par mois un atelier
discussions échanges jeu tout ça en
français
m
donc nous avons une association de 50 à
60 bénévoles qui se renie toute la
semaine ainsi que les samedis pour
donner des cours
donc en résidence comme vous pouvez le
voir ils sont occupés ils prennent des
cours de français et participe
activement à la vie du centre
en plus ils sont libres de sortir quand
bon leur semble à condition de revenir
au moins une fois tous les trois jours
donc on en parlait des migrants qui sont
installés du côté de bonnel et on a
aussi une soixantaine qui sont arrivés à
versailles tout à fait donc ils sont
arrivés le 30 avril
ils étaient 60 il visait en réalité
partie d'un campement qui était installé
sous le pont du métro aérien à
stalingrad à paris sous le métro
stalingrad à paris
ils ont été expulsés car le campement
devenu insalubre
ils ont donc été placés dans le centre
d'hébergement d'urgence des mortes mais
que l'on voit sur ces images qui se
trouve sur la route de versailles c'est
en fait un terrain militaire
ici on a deux nationalités différentes
des afghans et des sous d'année
principalement et ce sont
essentiellement des hommes isolés
écoutez yolande gros banc directrice
départementale adjointe de la cohésion
sociale que j'ai rencontrés sur place
on a des personnes qui ont déjà le
statut des réfugiés
d'autres qui ont déjà demandé un dossier
à paris qui ont déjà déposé un dossier à
paris et d'autres qui sont totalement en
situation irrégulière en fait il ya les
ali trois situations finalement donc
l'objectif c'est de clarifier la
situation de chacun de dresser des
listes
et puis ensuite à partir de ces listes
eh bien on va engager les personnes a
déposé le dossier auprès des services de
2 les îles alors ici on n'est pas sur la
même problématique que pour les réfugiés
syriens pour avoir le statut de réfugié
c'est du cas par cas d'ailleurs les
services de l'ofii et de lov prat
devrait les rencontrer cette semaine
aussi également sont libres ils ne sont
déjà aujourd'hui plus que 37 à vivre là
bas dans ce centre qui a administré par
la croix rouge
écoutez encore violent grobon qui nous
fait un point sur le nombre de réfugiés
dans les yvelines sur bonnel
on a en permanence une soixante soixante
tibétains et 15 afghans
donc ça fait 75 ensuite ici donc on a un
potentiel de 60
mais actuellement 37 sur triel on a 70
personnes et sur masi à peu près 90 soit
un total de 272 réfugiés migrants tout à
fait ça c'est pour ceux qui sont sous
l'autorité du préfet des yvelines
mais il ya aussi les personnes qui sont
hébergés en hôtel ou dans des foyers de
type adoma il se trouve à conflans
sainte honorine elancourt ou maurepas et
cela ne sont pas sous l'autorité sous
l'autorité du préfet des yvelines mais
sous celle du préfet de région
merci williams pour ce point complet sur
l'accueil des réfugiés et des migrants
dans notre département des yvelines dans
l'actualité également aujourd'hui le
déplacement de la ministre du logement
emmanuelle cosse nous irons à la
verrière où elle se trouve dans dans
quelques minutes pour faire un point sur
cette visite pour évoquer la thématique
du logement de l'habitat plus
globalement mais pour l'instant nous
poursuivons cette édition avec thibaut
mathieu bonsoir bonsoir mais pas encore
30 ans mais vous siégez déjà à l'onu
vous partez chaque mois à new york pour
le rotary club international
êtes vous arrivé à ce poste c'est une
excellente question
d'abord merci beaucoup de votre
invitation toujours un plaisir et donc
effectivement ce poste est à la voie à
une grande et mais surtout une très
belle surprise
une très belle surprise parce que ils
prouvent que tous les bénévoles à
travers le rotary club mais aussi à
travers d'autres grandes ong 1 je pense
aussi aux lions ce club parce que ce
sont des clubs services tous deux qu'ils
se mobilisent chaque année à travers
leur temps leur énergie et parfois même
leur porte monnaie au service du bien
commun et donc je suis très honoré
véritablement honoré de pouvoir les
représenter du moins d'avoir cette
petite voix au sein des nations unies à
new york
rotary club international alors pour
repréciser
une association qui rassemble plus de 35
mille club à travers le monde entier
plus de 200 pays
organisation qui est apolitique il ya
une devise servir d'abord
mais non on va se servir d'abord servir
d'abord absolument au départ j'ai
commencé par le rotaract club
d'accord la jeunesse du rotary les 18 30
ans et puis l'âge ce faisant et
s'avançant pour ma part j'aurai mes
trente printemps au juin prochain et
donc le rotary effectivement été là la
voie la plus naturelle et le rotary club
effectivement ce sont des générations
entières qui se mélangent pour essayer
de faire des actions pour pouvoir
récolter des fonds d'actions par exemple
concrètement et dans les yvelines il ya
quelques temps vous avez eu les potagers
solidaire vous avez également la récolte
de denrées alimentaires à travers la
banque alimentaire chaque chaque hiver
qui après distribuer au niveau local
très important et là par exemple au mois
de mai adrien cossart du rotary club de
versailles va organiser le premier
week-end européen où des jeunes du monde
entier vont venir célébrer l'europe
notamment où la journée du 7 et 8 mai si
on en revient à votre rôle de délégué au
sein de l'onu ça consiste en quoi
justement c'est échanger sur les
différentes actions qui sont menées
trouver de nouvelles idées alors s'est
trouvé une nouvelle idée c'est être
innovant cette termes d'innovation c'est
de porter une voix plus jeunes un peu
plus innovantes dans cette grande sphère
inde en sept ans ce temple de la
diplomatie internationale et surtout
avant de parler il faut savoir écouter
donc effectivement il ne suffit pas de
commencer à parler avec des grandes
phrases et à les amener des beaux mots
non il s'agit déjà de savoir quelle est
la réalité du terrain qu'il a les
réalités de chaque situation
la réussite est là la situation au sud
soudan n'est pas la même en syrie ou en
allemagne
et pour ne citer que ces angles ces
exemples-là pardon vous avez évidemment
des catastrophes naturelles
le retard est toujours là toujours
présent toujours présent quand il ya une
catastrophe qu'elles soient militaires
ou naturelle et donc cette petite voix
nations unies nous permet de faire
partie de ce monde et de pouvoir mieux
justement demain être sur le terrain
pour servir ce monde là vous avez changé
déjà vous avez si j'ai quelquefois donc
vous avez pu échanger avec vos
homologues d'une aide d'une hadmar de
chypre de république tchèque par exemple
fait parler de vos voisins wii 2 a fait
la réussite qu'est ce qui ressort un
petit peu qu'elle peut
différences y at il aussi dans la proche
de cette solidarité en fonction des pays
je suis avons pu vous surprendre alors
il ya toujours des pas mal d'anecdotes
je pense qu'ils vont venir au fur et à
mesure du temps mais la première chose
c'est que tout le monde de toute façon
est conscient peu importe le pays d'où
il vient
tout le monde est conscient que la
situation mondiale est catastrophique et
qu il faut il est important d'agir mais
d'agir intelligemment d'agir
intelligemment ça veut dire d'agir avec
les médias sociaux que nous avons la
révolution numérique et digital est
importante dans les résolutions de
beaucoup de conflits aujourd'hui mais
également elle est importante aussi
qu'on puisse se parler
quand on voit dans une petite anecdote
quand on voit que dans certaines
commissions la commission peut être
reportée ou annulée parce que
l'ambassadeur le délégué c'est le terme
onusien de la chine n'est pas présent
par exemple eh ben ça vous montre un
petit peu quel poids pèse chacun des
pays et savoure vous êtes obligé de
prendre du recul en train clairement du
recul mais je le dis je le répète une
fois que vous êtes dans l'hémicycle la
plupart du temps ce n'est pas de savoir
comment bien voter puisque ça vous le
savez comment vous allez voter
la chose la plus simple et la plus
claire à faire c'est d'être prêt au
moment où on va vous donner quelques
petites secondes de parole puisque avec
des centaines de délégués vous aimez
jettent un regard vraiment le temps est
absolument la seconde près il ya pas
malgré tout une frustration aussi dans
le fait de siéger à l'onu parce que on
le sait il n'ya pas de pouvoir de
sanction par exemple absolument
chaque état est souverain voilà le
juriste que je suis peul en plus
affirmée chaque état est souverain et
donc les nations unies peuvent très bien
donner des dizaines de résolutions par
jour pour infliger telle ou telle
sanction un pays ce n'est pas pour ça
que ce pays va se sentir menacés ou
encore mieux puni il n'y a pas de
frustration
malgré tout ça dépend des sanctions ça
dépend effectivement des situations la
guerre en irak l'onu s'était prononcé
contre l'invasion de l'irak par les
américains
les américains n'ont pas tenu compte et
sont quand même y aller effectivement je
pense que ce type de blocage n'est pas
forcément une frustration mais je pense
pas que ce ce job soit inutile je pense
qu'il est utile aujourd'hui de pouvoir
parler avec le monde entier de pouvoir
avancer ensemble
vous parlez de job justement parce que
la politique pour vous c'est un peu un
job ça pourrait le devenir vous étiez
candidat à versailles lors des dernières
élections municipales versailles elle
nous rassemble c'est un mouvement qui a
la culture qui est aujourd'hui toujours
quels sont vos visées politiques
justement vous prenez à l'onu comme un
tremplin
alors non c'est ni un tremplin ya un
marchepied c'est d'abord une expérience
une expérience enrichissante extrêmement
enrichissante sur le plan humain et sur
le plan des idées et deuxièmement la
politique pour moi n'est pas un métier
mais c'est d'abord à 20 ans avant tout
un devoir et je ne me suis pas encore
prononcé sur l'avenir politique à
versailles mais il est sûr que je crois
qu'il arrive je serai quoi
après un jeu je suis l'actualité
versaillaise avec assiduité et je puis
d'ailleurs me réjouir aujourd'hui par
exemple parce que je parle toujours tout
ce monde là je connais et ce sont aussi
des amis je parle par exemple je pense à
olivier de la faire à un conseiller
général et qui aujourd'hui le
représentant des du comité olympique
pour le département des yvelines est
bien avec mon cher ami olivier bien nous
parlons de l'équitation
équitation qui est aujourd'hui un sport
mais un sport qui va être plus que
représentait à versailles et dans
pendant ma campagne j'avais
effectivement dit que je vous souhaitez
à titre personnel que versailles
devienne une capitale équestre et grâce
au travail exemplaire que le petit
château de versailles a pu accomplir
catherine pégard et toute son équipe et
olivier dans un autre temps et ainsi que
la société des amis qu'on oublie mais il
faut un travail absolument incroyable eh
bien on va peut être avoir ces épreuves
là au château qui va pouvoir nous donner
une respiration versaillaise que
franchement on a besoin puisque il faut
pas s'il faut pas se tromper
le lac tracts ivité touristique de
versailles n'est pas une chose acquise
vous avez un discours politique déjà
bien rodée on va faire comme à l'onu je
vais chronométrés votre temps de parole
pour une réponse très claire il ya des
législatives en 2010 est en france pour
le coup ça vous intéresse ça vous
intéresse pas vous y pensez je me suis
rasé ce matin voilà donc vous y avez
pensé
merci pour traduire tout ça merci à
mathieu merci délégué donc du rotary
club international qui siègent donc à
l'onu merci santé à présent dans ce
journal est le second volet à présent de
ce portrait que nous avons consacré à
anaïs vous avez découvert dans notre
édition d'hier cette petite fille de
cinq ans qui est atteint de tetra paresi
une forme d'infirmité moteur cérébral
qui la rend
handicapé des quatre membres ses parents
lui font pratiques et de plusieurs
méthodes de rééducation voici la suite
de ce reportage consacré à cette famille
réalisé par william l après avoir passé
sa journée entre l'école et l'hôpital
anaïs rentrer chez elle mais sa journée
n'est pas terminée
soucieux du développement de leur fille
les parents sont allés chercher plus
loin que ce que pouvait proposer la
médecine française des méthodes dites
alternatives souvent non reconnu par la
france
c'est beaucoup d'investissement parce
que du coup il faut rééduquer donc tout
aussi bien la main sur la parole que les
bras et du coup au quotidien il faut la
halle à stimuler la solliciter même si
elle est très très volontaire et qu'elle
après très envie de progresser
ces thérapies c'est à l'étranger que les
parents sont allés les chercher
méthode et santis biofeedback ou encore
la méthode medek à laquelle anaïs
s'exerce tous les soirs en redescendre
doucement aux pieds les jambes puis les
jambes mais les mains devant je te tiens
qu'est l'inde mains des exercices qui
expose l'enfant à la gravité dans
l'objectif d'obtenir une réponse active
elle fait des exercices en fait par
exemple en monte mon temps sur sur des
boîtes en bois où on la met en situation
de déséquilibre pour qu'elles puissent
appréhender et retrouver son équilibre
et ça lui permet comme ça de garder une
posture bien plus droite méthode très
physique mais chronophage pour les
parents anaïs réalise tous les soirs des
séances d'une demi-heure environ mais
qui selon eux portent leurs fruits
on a vu qu à laquelle faisait énormément
de progrès notamment sur la marche parce
que là au mois de décembre elle a pu
faire ses premiers pas tout seul et on
essaie de la simuler au quotidien pour
pour qu'elle puisse continuer à
c'est une partie de ces thérapies se
fait à l'étranger notamment en espagne
des déplacements très coûteux qui ont
nécessité la création d'une association
pour aider au financement de ses soins
mais aussi pour le matériel trop peu
remboursés par les assurances sociales
s'arrête
anaïs une petite fille extrêmement
soutenue par ses parents qui mettent
toutes les chances de son côté pour
améliorer son état physique avec
l'espoir de la voir peut-être un jour
marcher et parler comme tout le monde et
le portrait complet de cette petite
fille dont kamel sera retrouvée dans le
prochain numéro de check up à l'antenne
sur tv fil 78 en replay sur notre site
internet un tout autre sujet à présent
les fermes de gally organisé ce week-end
ses deuxièmes universités du goût le
goût du bon la provenance des produits
l'origine du goût aussi autant de
questions qui ont été développées lors
de conférences et d'ateliers pratiques
bien évidemment retour sur cette journée
avec mélanie poker patrick jacques de
dixmude à quel jeu de paume et le plus
sucré lequel est le plus acide les sens
des visiteurs des fermes de gally ont
été mis à contribution ce week-end et
plus précisément le goût nous qui sommes
à l'origine du goût de certains produits
parce que sur la façon dont on plante
les produits en les arrosant les
cultivent le produit le végétal pour ce
concerne la pomme par exemple va avoir
ou peut avoir un goût différent
et comme on est à l'origine de goût
était important aussi qu'on arrive à
faire comprendre aux uns ou aux autres
donc à partager
avec l'ensemble des gens qui sont des
mangeurs pour c'est pas des citoyens
données économiques le mangeur c'est
vous moi donc de partager avec eux la
façon dont ça se produit et ça
fonctionne avec la présence de médecins
nutritionnistes de philosophes ou encore
de producteurs ces universités sont
l'occasion de comprendre d'où vient le
bon goût est d'identifier ceux qu'on
aime ou non il s'agit de déguster et
donc des chocolats et d'en faire une
traduction
un sucré à ces deux légèrement amer
aussi en fin de bouche en astringent
sourcils et aussi l'aspect physique
c'est à dire si les fins fonds dans sle
crémeux croustillant ça permet d'avoir
une vision différente du goût et ça
marche très bien c'est à chaque fois
qu'on essayait un chocolat on faisait
une visualisation en 3d
l'atelier j'ai trouvé que c'était
intéressant puisque la pomme c'est un
fruit qui est très très connu en fait
très répandue on pourrait même dire que
c'est presque banal mais finalement il
ya beaucoup de il ya un large panel de
sensations et au niveau de la texture au
niveau du goût des eaux de rap
cette journée a rassemblé plus de 300
personnes
une troisième édition des universités du
goût est déjà prévue pour l'année
prochaine
le parc fonctionne a turquie a rouvert
ses portes ce week end après sa
traditionnelle coupure hivernale le
public a pu re découvrir les monuments
français mais aussi les dernières
attractions comme la grotte et le champ
de fouilles cette réouverture était
aussi l'occasion pour le parc de
proposer de nouvelles animations on
écoute les premiers visiteurs
c'est plutôt sympa déjà l'ensemble des
des monuments c'est intéressant et puis
la partie attraction là qui est super
pour les enfants en plus on a la chance
on a le soleil ne le croyais à beaucoup
d espace
il ya plein de traction le détail puis
le comment le voyage ont fait le voyage
partout en france quoi non sans y est
allé c'est vraiment extraordinaire il y
avait vraiment des points de détails sur
les monuments c'est les commentaires
sont intéressants aussi pour pouvoir s'y
retrouver
autre parc autre nouveauté depuis le 2
avril le parc zoologique de thoiry
invite ses visiteurs à découvrir son
labyrinthe sous un autre jour les 6000
mètres carrés de son parcours sont
dorénavant le théâtre d'une mission pour
aider et sauver les animaux on y tourne
on y trouve 15 animaux fantastiques
protégées dont 4 animatronics écouter
collombat de lapanouse directrice
générale déléguée du parc qui a conçu
cette animation
en fait on a un jeune biologiste qui
s'appelle no et lui veut sauver les
espèces menacées et son petit frère fou
fou lui il a créé plein d'animaux
extraordinaires qui n'existe pas et il
les a mélangé avec les animaux du zoo
donc la mission c'est d'aider nos et à
remettre de l'ordre dans tout ça parce
que maintenant c'est tout mélanger et
c'est vraiment n'importe quoi
animations à découvrir au parc de thoiry
pour cette nouvelle saison et pour
terminer ce journal retour sur la
compétition qui passionne chaque soir
près chaque semaine chaque mardi soir
près de 3 millions de téléspectateurs
c'est top chef sur m6 en douze semaines
de compétition pour xavier pincemin à
seulement 26 ans il est le second du
restaurant gastronomique gordon ramsay
deux étoiles du trianon palace à
versailles il vient de se qualifier pour
la finale
nous sommes allés le rencontrer dans ses
cuisines un sujet de sephora namani et
mélanie poker
vous aviez pincement à 26 ans et le
finaliste de top chef
second du gordon ramsay restaurant
gastronomique deux étoiles du trianon
palace de versailles
il opère le même rituel tous les matins
arrivé à 8h ils se changent et monte en
cuisine
la mise en place commence mon paul
albert la salle en commun de jeu au pied
commun donc douze semaines de
compétition top chef déjà pour xavier
pincemin une aventure éprouvante et
riche en apprentissages un
épanouissement perceptible pour ce jeune
cuisinier depuis gp top chef machine a
évolué parce que j'essaie de donner plus
mon identité à moi parce que derrière
avant j'étais vraiment derrière simonet
maintenant je sais vraiment bête de me
donner à mon style de cuisine est un peu
plus créatif on va dire j'ai pris plus
de confiance en moi par rapport aux
services le rapport avec l'équipe il est
de plus en plus fort c'est vrai que je
suis je suis plus en plus passionné par
mon métier je suis sous chef du
restaurant gastronomique et donc mon
rôle c'est de contrôler ce que font tous
les gars avec qui je bosse c'est à dire
que jouer aux garnitures et ba hy cuisse
et asperges
je regarde si elles sont bien les
peluches et si elles sont à son bel au
niveau de la couleur le calibre et si le
bout et mon l'assaisonnement la cuisson
le matin je vous trouve comme ça ce soir
pendant le service irs pas de problème
en semaine le restaurant de 50 couverts
n'est ouvert que le soir xavier et son
chef simonet zanoni en profite pour
retravailler la carte en fonction des
saisons et des arrivages quotidiens
une complicité et un respect mutuels
partagé depuis huit ans qui a poussé le
chef inscrire son poulain au concours
top chef
je me suis dit que j'avais un bon
candidat j'avais quelqu'un converse avec
je pense qu'il était arrivé à un certain
maturité et je pense que c'était un beau
challenge pour lui c'est techniquement
et humainement c'est quand même même si
de temps en temps
on essaie de le faire passer pour chacun
d un peu arrogant pour quelqu'un d'un
peu pour sûr de lui en fait on va
l'essayer n'est pas du tout comme ça on
est très confiant jusqu'à la fin de
belle qualité pour peut-être décrocher
la finale
mais en attendant retour en cuisine à 18
heures pour les derniers contrôles
qualité avant de démarrer le service
xavier brive sa brigade de douze
cuisiniers et l'équipe de service en
salle
on a des clients importants à table 4
donc il ya une personne sans gluten 20
heures le service démarre le second
rejoint son pass annonce des commandes
vérification des assiettes l'adrénaline
augmente
attention et qu'elle me sont de rigueur
et si seuls parce c'est là où je
travaille avec simonet c'est à dire que
c'est un petit peu le dernier endroit où
on a un contrôle sur rouge attendait sur
l'assiette
ouais marche de menus découverte avec
deux foires à deux turbos rosé de veau
rosé la passion de la cuisine pour moi
c'est venu depuis tout petit parce que
c'est vrai que mes parents il
travaillait beaucoup et j'avais besoin
de voir tout le monde et la seule façon
de voir c'était le bal de dîner avec eux
mois avant est ce que je faisais je te
paraît dîner en option tout seul et
péter kramer arrivé voilà on se retrouve
en cuisine ont passé tous à table
une passion qu'il espère bien honorer en
décrochant la finale de top chef 2016
lundi 18 avril et devenir ainsi le 7e
gagnant de l'aventuré culinaire c'est
moi qui vais y arriver pourquoi parce
que je suis motivé je suis pareil jusque
là pour rien mon chef qui est juste là
qui attend quand même
c'est important pour lui jusqu'au bout
et je veux pas décevoir mes parents ni
ma famille c'est mon rêve depuis tout
petit c'est d'être chef étoilé et on y
croit j'y crois toujours et puis je vois
pourquoi ça marche pour les autres et
pas pour moi et on y va
table 12 pas dit doucement sommet
verdict donc de top chef dans une petite
semaine lundi soir nous partons donc je
vous le disais au début de cette édition
pour la verrière avec emmanuelle cosse
la ministre du logement qui est en
déplacement actuellement elle rencontre
les élus pour évoquer et des projets
d'éco quartiers d'habitat participatif
sur place également pour la rédaction
mélanie poquet bonsoir mélanie ont
formulé la ministre henry qui doit donc
rester jusqu'au début de la soirée
qu'elle est calé son programme alors
elle notamment venus participer à une
table ronde sur le thème habiter
autrement à la verrière l'équipe
municipale est actuellement en train de
lui présenter les différents projets de
construction de logements de la commune
vous l'avez blir l'habitat participatif
et celui de garder calme qui confirme le
nord de la ville ce projet une fiente de
nitrates pour la commune et
l'agglomération de 51000 et prévoit la
construction de 1800 logements un pôle
gare rénovée et 8,6 modèle est aussi un
pôle d'activité d'environ 80 mètres
carrés
les travaux devraient commencer en 2017
merci mélanie nous reviendrons sur ce
déplacement de la ministre à la verrière
dans notre édition de demain avec un
reportage complet bien évidemment le 7 8
le journal est terminé pour ce soir dans
un instant sur tv fils de 7,8 société
nouradine agne et qui évoquera les jo de
2024 quelles opportunités pour st
quentin en yvelines c'est la question
qu'il posera à ses invités qui vont
débattre dans un instant je vous
souhaite une excellente soirée